I come to this video this is a dual
comentary game again with a rapid time
control 10 minutes plus 10 seconds per
move and I'm playing against my friend
Brandon here from from YouTube it's got
another hand layer they could nod is
also the the channel name if I am not
mistaken I'll propose the link in the
description so we both be doing them
commentor he on this game um okay we got
a Queen's Indian I'm varying openings as
usual i'm not sure what is playing
against the Queen sinyun here white main
options are g3a3 93 couple of moves 83
yeah okay I'll down there should be
seven g6 this is some an interesting
line a bit provocative of course but
it's it's interesting the main line is d
5 which is rather solid yeah 3 is owned
a very modest move white also could have
played them for reform with Quincy to
for example okay able to of course this
is some healthy way to develop your
pieces yum ok I have fun multiple ideas
see how to set up a centre I can play
with d5 I could play see 5 or I could
play something like d6d 697 to ER to
stay flexible ok I'll try that
this is also set up that black can
employ if white would play Queen c2 and
c4 on move six so on if white would play
eve for now yeah but it's still a good
move of course um then this is quite
similar to this other line with Quincy
284 but wide span two moves with the
upon yeah of course okay he moves on and
sent upon himself this is interesting
what I want to say is of course at one
point I need to yeah move something in
the center so what now move like 94
maybe Nyjah 435 an idea but an annid
g-form item take on e6 and play 95 could
be M could be a problem okay play a
neutral first I'm not quite sure how to
set up pieces here taking only six
shouldn't be a big problem i can just
recapture gal with the porn even yeah
what should why do at some suddenly am
an okay position for black but it f over
white but it's not so easy to UM to make
some concrete progress here cannot
really push something in the center and
before gets answered by maybe just 94
you could try to prepare this okay
rookie one is some yeah a bit of a
nothing move but it doesn't do any
damage also I've got a phone call sorry
need to take this later okay so what
should I do I can play some waiting move
still maybe something like this not v5
could be irritating
you
yeah if I were as wide I think i would
consider them like Age 3 here maybe okay
you heard me yeah well I didn't but the
energy for was a possible idea energy 45
so on yeah what now what should be M
what's the right plan in this position
it's not on easy maybe maybe night to
each five night h5 with ideas of maybe
taking on c3 and then play a 5 this I
like the idea but tonight h5 he can also
simply play and move like we should be
too but then maybe 95 mm okay I think it
would be really good if I would be able
to trade one or two Pierce of minor
pieces and Bishop takes you three years
I'm positional idea that it's not so
easy to I mean either the other way
around it's easy to um yeah not
appreciate this idea I think it would
lead to a very nice structure for black
if I would be able to take that he needs
to recapture with a pawn takes an e5 and
then it's all closed and the Queen side
is completely blocked so that I can
certainly play something like 95 you
should see eight so Bishop takes c3 is
really um yeah I think it's a threat
ready he needs to learn to do something
about this one idea
be to play on you should chief I first
and then maybe drop it back to 2d too
haha ok ok let's let's go for this I'm
glad I have something to play for my
heart doesn't respond immediately so we
didn't really expect this move so now
the cool side is completely closed and
one idea could be Bishop c8 of course I
don't want to have this Bishop on b7 all
the time it's just biting on granite ESL
Bishop c8 and maybe then if then f5 even
directly f5 f5 and 19 f 6 so Bishop c 8
97 f 59 f 697 i think i didn't i didn't
mention but this is also part of the
plan ok neither for irritates him but ok
i want to get the bishop to c8 anywhere
now i'm lining up a bit against yep
against the porn so should i retreat now
2 g's seven-armed immediately have five
looks looks bit weird can take and take
efan h5 neither saying hmm yep ok let's
drop this back mmm and that's
interesting now what should why do the
only meaningful pawn break is now a form
maybe why should try to prepare for in
some way you know maybe in ith form
mileage for could be considered night
each form and then I'm going to play a
five takes tags and F form all night
back to 22 well D to maybe store with
the idea of playing f4 and f5 yeah I
need to be a bit cautious with the f5 it
done easily could be a mistimed I also
have the Queen on his heaven opposite
the rook so um need to be extra cautious
there when when the position is opened
up alright yeah ok don't want it to play
a five not sure if F or can be a problem
also for white if a bishop comes to d7
that constantly attacked the spawn and
somewhat slower idea that I could cut
rise on Knight to f6 king edge eight and
nine to g8 but ok an i have 60 my play
Bishop g5 then I'm gonna really are
really bad in I don't want to do that
195 is this an IBM I mean you can always
take but then I went down not sure if i
should play 95 ok i'll i'll go for this
if you take some it's really some some
concession giving away the bishop and
after i am threatening a night be three
yards oh but you play some bishop c2
which looks like them the normal
reaction then none I can play Bishop d7
Bishop e6 I could also play the tech in
c4 and the only has very awkward moves
to to cover only Queenie to really yeah
but the ship on a six is really a silly
piece an interesting move from yes maybe
okay he captured yeah interesting now
how should I recapture yeah well the
normal rule for PT take c5 to clear d 6
for the night yeah okay
don't waste too much time and developing
brand new brilliant ideas and then
overstep the time I'll write the night
let's go to d6 anyway yeah now this
night on d6 it's really a great piece at
xe4 and c4 and um yeah also Bishop d7
hula coming which attacks efore also so
strategically this is a really nice
position why it's only players connected
with f4 and dumb yeah his pieces are not
really well positioned to play F for any
time soon yeah this 96 is really nice
yes preparing a for after all okay so
Bishop d7 completing development and um
yeah tickling the a4 porn white would
need to play some really ugly move to
keep them keep it covered Quincy to
queen e to something like this yeah rook
rook a one the mighty rook used her just
for defending upon okay so centralize
all and yeah maybe it maybe even at five
at some I'm pretty well positioned now
to go f5 f5 phone would put lots of
fresh only for saw him he must take it I
think oh wait c4 is hanging right any
reason not to take it nope okay let's
grab a pawn yeah it's not the most
important porn ever but it's still upon
so what would happen if them he goes f4
know how he didn't yeah should I play a
fight fear I guess so don't want to play
too passively
yeah it's also just good for me after
FYI can take a form and should have a
big advantage and if it takes on f5 I
can even consider taking with the bishop
I can also take with the poem if I take
with the pawn on f5 then F form at some
common idea it's um it's still very nice
for me i can and play eve form without
any big problems i can simply let him
take on e5 with the move like I don't
know Queen g7 or something or queen f6
and after takes only 5 45 I'm quick on
the farm yeah okay that the thing is I
have a perfect structure on the
queenside with this which is great night
on d6 really keeps everything together
ok I thought this wasn't playable f
takes before Bishop before takes on f4
shouldn't this win the game I don't know
that looks winning ready I said some
tricky takes our form Knight takes
Knight e form I don't think so ok
yeah the only idea would be nice f-for
94-96 but still I can't believe that
this would be any good no it isn't i can
also play wave to us for instance i'm
talking about night air for 94-96 look f
to check and now i'm just a double
attacking ye form yeah i think what
really needs to yeah move the bishop
again yeah something like this so what
now take on i can just take on g3
grabbing another pawn but maybe there is
some some even better alternative here
it really looks like there should be
something like f3r some moves our way to
f3 Bishop takes and then see for how
does he protect our three I guess he
doesn't write tonight f1 I'm so stupid
can just play night at four alright yeah
I could have just taken g3 and it sir
it's just two problems for nothing yeah
forget about night at four
oh yeah lida form would have been good I
could take ya quickly I can take you one
room okay still should be good for me
still this was unnecessary I can just
take g3 and it's basically curtains yeah
now I don't see how he protects it
lightly really resigns yeah he resigned
yeah I think the real key point in the
game even wassallam was here he had this
move it should be three when I was able
to capture and play a five and this
leads to a very nice position as these
doubled pawns really have no way to way
forward c5 is so nicely located so um I
have from the queenside completely
secured and he still got some weaknesses
then I might use in the long run and i
still have ideas on the Kings Island
yeah this is basically how it went it
gave me the c-4 point on the way but
this is pretty much rather one-sided
position White is still okay if he
defends good on the defense well on the
on the King side then there shouldn't be
so much danger danger for him but it's
certain that white doesn't have anything
special to do and it's rather one-sided
I think around here with some
improvements that maps will be okay a4
for example helps me getting some point
of a check on a for this is why if I was
played and now this year yeah and I
think this is really a huge concession
why shouldn't take probably Bishop situ
or something it's certainly a nice
position for black but I think Bishop c5
helps this is only good if you could
d6 quickly so let's say here if y would
be able to play d6 quickly let's say
i'll do some some slow moves that don't
make much sense here something like this
then this might might be an idea for
white sv6 is a problem but in the game I
was quick on d6 with one night and now
56 is never possible and yet yeah this
is just just very one-sided now I think
what might still be okay with perfect
play but it's um it's certainly a bit
better for like yeah I hope you will
enjoy it we as mentioned both the
documentary on off the game so check the
link in the description to also yeah
watch Brandon's version of this thanks
for watching and yeah hope to see you
soon with new videos